In the last video we talked
about the situation where I'm
taking 9 shots on a goal.
We knew my probability of
making any given shot, and what
we wanted to do is figure out
the probability distribution of
me making k shots, in general.
We defined our random
variable, x, as the number
of shots I make out of 6.
So I realized in that last
example and that example is
right back here, that the
math gets a little hairy.
You're dealing with 0.7 then
times 0.3 to the fifth
and all of that.
So it got a little complicated
and what better thing to do if
you have numbers like this,
even better than the
calculator than to use Excel.
And you'll see that Excel is
a fairly powerful tool for
probability and statistics.
And in general, for a lot
of types of simulations.
If you don't want to actually
write serious code you can
actually do fairly serious
things with something as
seemingly not so simple, or
not so serious as Excel.
But it's actually
quite serious.
So let's see.
So let's say that I'm going
to take-- let's define n.
I'm going to say that that is,
I'm going to take 6 shots.
The probability of me making
any shot I'll say is 0.3.
That's what we did
in the last video.
The probability of a miss,
let me actually write it a
little bit more explicitly.
Probability of a make is equal
to 0.3 and the probability of a
miss I'm going to write-- and
instead of just writing 0.7
there because we know it is,
let's just it a little bit
dependent on the first one.
So write out the formula, we'll
say that's equal to 1 minus--
and then we'll select
this cell right here.
It's equal to 1 minus the
probability that I make a
shot, And notice it just
calculated it for us, 0.7.
Let me zoom in a little bit.
There you go.
That might be easier
for you to read.
Because I know it gets
really small on YouTube.
And this is neat because now if
we wanted to see what happens
when this becomes 0.2
that automatically
calculates to 0.8.
So that's neat.
Let's just put it back to 0.3.
And now let's do a bunch of
rows so that we can calculate
the probability that our random
variable, x, could be 0
shots or 1 shot or whatever.
So let's say that k-- let
me make a row called k.
So that's the number of
shots we need to make.
So 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
You can't see the sixth one
right now, let me just go
up here and now you
can see everything.
And then we need to figure out
the binomial coefficient.
Well actually,
let's do it first.
Let's say the probability of
making any one of those,
any one way of getting no
shots, or any one way of
getting exactly 3 shots.
So that's going to be the
probability of a make.
So you're going to make it.
You're going to make k shots
times the probability
of a miss.
So if you make k shots,
how many do you miss?
You miss n minus k.
And I'm not doing anything
fancy in Excel right here.
I'm just kind of writing a
label that hopefully is a
little intuitive for you.
So this is the probability--
this column is going to be-- in
this cell right here is going
to be the probability that any
one particular way of making
3 shots and missing 3 shots.
It's going to go in
that cell eventually.
And then you need to know
that you needed the
binomial coefficient.
It's going to look a
little bit messy now.
So you want n choose k.
So essentially this row is
going to say, what's the
probability for example, in
this cell right here we'll have
the probability of making the
first and missing the next 5,
or missing the first 5
and making the last 1.
They're all going to be
the same probability.
You're going to have
1 make and 5 misses.
And then, this cell we're
going to say, well, how
many different ways can
I make just 1 out of 6?
And that's why I'm going
to choose 1 out of 6.
k is 1 and n is 6.
That's going to go there.
And then we can calculate what
the probability that our random
variable is equal to k,
is equal to this value.
And it looks all fancy, but
it's exactly what we did in
the last video with my little
doodle tool that I use.
Which is actually just
Microsoft Paint for those of
you wondering because I get a
lot of e-mails and I'm tired
of saying it's just
Microsoft Paint.
All right, so what's the
probability that I make 0
and I miss 6 because that's
what they're saying here.
So this is going to be the
probability of me making a
shot-- and I'll put
those dollar signs.
That kind of fixes
it on this cell.
The probability that I make
a shot to the kth power.
So I make 0 shots times the
probability that I miss a shot.
Put those dollar signs there so
that it fixes on that cell--
to the n minus k power.
In this case it would
be the sixth power.
I miss 6 six shots, so
to the-- let me put it
in parentheses-- n.
Let me fix on that cell.
n minus k power.
And there you go there.
That's the probability for
example, of me making the
first and missing the next 5.
Or this could be the
probability of me getting the
first shot, then missing the
second, and getting
the last 4 missed.
So any of one of
those situations.
And how many of those
situations are there?
Well that's n choose k.
So that's equal to-- n
choose k-- that's the
same thing we did before.
That's all this
factorial stuff here.
That's n choose k.
So I'm just going to express
the binomial coefficient
expression in Excel.
So it's a factorial of how many
we're choosing from, how many
shots we're taking, and the
Excel function for
that is fact.
So we'll take the factorial of
6 and we'll divide it by--
put a parentheses here.
The factorial of k times
the factorial of n.
Let me fix that n.
Minus k.
And I know it fell off.
n minus k.
You put some parentheses there,
so the parentheses match up.
Actually, this what fixes
on this cell Let me
put an F4 there.
And then there you go.
There's only one way to choose
0 things out of 6 things.
That's what that tells us.
And then the probability that
my random variable is equal to
k, or in this case, that I make
exactly 0 shots is equal to the
probability of any of the
specific ways of making 0 shots
times the number of those
ways there are times that.
So that's the probability
of making 0 shots.
And this is a cool thing
about Excel, we can now
select these cells.
And just go into this right
hand corner, just drag it
down, and it'll do that
calculation for all of them.
And this is neat because
it calculated the
binomial coefficients.
This is 6 choose 3.
n is 6, k is 3.
This is 6 choose 3 is 20.
It's nice and symmetric
like you would expect.
But the probabilities aren't
that symmetric because
we have 0.3 and 0.7.
So it's not like the flipping
a coin example that was
0.5 on either side.
Sorry, these aren't symmetric
and then when you multiply
these, of course, these
don't looks symmetric.
But it's hard to look at these
numbers, so actually, let's
just use the powers of Excel to
graph this probability
distribution.
So let's say insert chart.
I'm always, I'm clumsy
at inserting charts,
so let me see.
The data-- I think
this is how I do it.
I select the data.
There you go.
And then I need to select the
label, the category x labels.
OK, that's going to
be that right there.
And then let's see.
Next, that looks good.
I don't want to have anything.
I don't need a legend.
I don't want to show a legend.
There you go.
All right.
Now I think I'm finished.
Data labels-- yeah,
that's fine.
OK, finish.
I don't want to get too fancy.
Don't want the
letters [INAUDIBLE].
Let me make this
bigger for you.
So this is neat and I wish
they didn't make the font so
big, but you get the point.
This is a discreet probability
distribution of me making, in
this case, k shots out of 6.
And this was based on the fact
that my probability of making
any given shot was 0.3.
Let me see if it'll actually--
and I'm not making any promises
here-- let me see if I can
actually make it so
that it changes.
If I make it 0.2
does it change?
Oh, it changed!
Look at that.
That was neat.
Let me bring this
up a little bit.
So what's neat is if I have a
30% chance of making a free
throw, that is my probability
distribution, my discrete
probability distribution
of making k shots.
This is my probability
of making no shots.
I think it was like roughly--
oh, it even gives us it.
Tell us it's 0.12% or it's 12%
chance of making no shots.
My probability of making
4 shots is only 6%.
I know you can't see it but
that little window that
shows up right under
my pointer says 0.06.
So this is neat.
And since the way we set it up
we can actually change it,
so that if I have a higher
probability of making a shot,
now it looks pretty symmetric.
Now my chances of making 4
shots is the same as my
chances of making 2 shots.
And if I'm really good at
making baskets, I have
an 80% probability of
making any given shot.
Now, all of a sudden, the
whole distribution has
shifted to the right.
But I just wanted to show you
one, this is, I think, a
pretty neat way to use Excel.
And hopefully, it's
not too daunting.
The other thing is, these are
all examples of binomial
distributions and I wanted to
give you an example that might
be a little bit more relevant
to your everyday life.
The probabilities of making
and missing aren't the
same, they change.
If they are the same
then you end up with a
situation like that.
Let's say you're a horrible
basketball player and you
only have a 10% chance of
making any given shot.
So there's a very high
probability that
you make no shots.
There's a 53% chance you make
no shots and then there's a
35% chance you make one shot,
and so forth and so on.
But this is pretty neat.
This by itself is kind of a fun
little toy and hopefully you
have enough information to do
it yourself, or maybe
experiment with more.
What happens if you
have more than n?
Actually, maybe I'll do
that in the next video.
Anyway, see you soon.